Jay Worthy's here what's up Kev very
rare Jay worthy interview in 2023 good
to see you man yeah good to see you too
man we always catch each other out in uh
functions yes sir man you've been
working so hard bro appreciate that you
got the tour coming up I got the tour
coming up yeah first leg of the tour
um excited about that you know what I'm
saying
perform some new material about to come
out so always good you know yeah I feel
like you have a pretty uh insane output
when it comes to just like putting out
bodies of work bro like
for you like Woody what would you kind
of attribute the work ethic to just you
feel it feels like you figured it out
yeah you know
um
I don't know man you know like I I
studied the great you know what I'm
saying and um
you know just
even I must say it just watching POC
like when he was in the studio he would
tell them like look we're gonna lay all
this [__] down mix and master that [__]
later let's get the verses done on to
the next like I'm always trying to get
to the finish line and um
and it's easy to do when you're like
working on a project with one producer
so for example if I lock in with fraud
we're in there like I just left New York
I was there for a week we did
10 records and two sessions you know
what I'm saying and you guys already got
two albums yeah we got two albums and
this next one is uh me and kamiyah all
produced by um fraud oh yeah man I
wanted to put her on you know like some
different [__] yeah yeah you know
because I I feel like I'm good at you
know I can a r and curate things well so
it's cool to like you know I'm like well
you know what that hasn't been done
before let's do that you know for people
who don't know man give us your
background obviously you're from La kind
of how long you've been making music
where you're from what part of the city
you're from you know from the west side
of Compton
um
um I've been doing this [__] a little
minute you know I kind of came into the
game with yams he was the first one to
kind of discover me
um
you know put out a project in the
SoundCloud ERA with fool's gold and then
my debut EP was with um Alchemist in
2017 that's when I started like
streaming and putting music out so you
know we we got we still knew we still on
the first run you know what I'm saying
I'm gonna run it up some more
but you know
um I've been in the game of you know a
little second I guess
um how did ASAP yams discover you so me
and yams uh we met in Texas you know
what I'm saying and
the way that we met was kind of crazy I
was out [__] around uh at South by
Southwest we was on the same like
showcases or whatnot
um
and he just took a liking to me bro he
was like man I [__] with this dude and
you know we had mutual friends like Dash
and stuff and it was a lot of [__] going
on at southbound I think there was like
a rumble somewhere at the fader Ford or
some [__] like that it was that year but
anyways it was wild and out there we got
along and
um at the time I was living with um big
face uh games Brother on uh Brazil in
Wilmington and I brought Dash over there
that's um
uh I don't know if you know who Dash is
but he used to rap with them a lot too
that's um Dame Dash nephew and I put him
on a joint and we shot a video and yams
liked it and you know what I'm saying
and this time I was kind of figuring out
my sound I was like you know I just
wanted to rap over oldies and you know
Lube [__] up
um
yeah you know so he kind of gave me the
direction like you know he get he put
the confidence in me because before I
was just rapping in the hood right with
the homies and the only like you know
success I had seen at the time you know
was like game or uh you know uh I used
to run around with sugar and you know
just soak up game from him but
this was some new [__] you know what I'm
saying and I I like the way the
direction like I like the way the music
was going and like this was around like
everybody was hanging out at Fairfax and
I'm just you know what I'm saying Street
Wear culture skateboard and all that
type of [__] and I was like oh this [__]
is cool and it can get me out of the
hood so
um you know I started [__] around and
moving in those circles a little bit
okay what year were you running around
with Suge Knight damn shook probably
like young like
2008 nine yeah maybe 2007 even yeah yeah
yeah shook would give me a lot of game
man um you know and bring bring us
around and stuff and um
but you know I I seen the game change
and and you know I had to take a
different approach and um
you know you got to move with the times
you know what I'm saying how did you
guys initially connect who me and should
yeah well just you know just Compton
[__] you know what I'm saying so
um you know some of the big homies
um you know was [__] with him and you
know brought me around him and he took a
liking to me and are you making music at
this time uh I was but I was like you
know I'd kind of like I'd gotten you
know more caught up in Street [__] I'm
not gonna lie and like music was just
like second secondary yeah it was like a
hobby but
I um you know I definitely still did it
but it wasn't like you know what I'm
saying I was I didn't know really what
direction to go in yet you know what I'm
saying I didn't really have my sound
like before I started doing this stuff
is learning drugs
I'd put out one tape with mustard and um
I would just take different songs from
different Studios and I'm like mustard
was the homie so he hosted it yeah
before he was making beats yeah this is
he was making BT it just did Rack City
okay so like and then Nema had hit me
that's how I got in the Empire system
because I remember I just threw the tape
out there this is still like like
physicals and like
um a couple of my boys that were uh from
like the jungles
um they were like instead of just
putting the tapes
um
and swap meets and liquor stores around
the hood you should go up to Fairfax and
put it in the hundreds and supreme and
diamonds yeah yeah yeah so that kind of
like brought me up there and then
um you know people on that side of town
started hearing my [__] so I was like
you know I had the right intentions to
do it but I wasn't like it wasn't until
like you know I got with Sean and
started like you know really figuring
out my sound and what I wanted to do and
then um you know with the helper yeah it
was just kind of
showing me the ropes a little bit you
know yams did a lot he put me with Vice
and then that led into me producing that
um documentary with Kendrick or about
Kendrick and my homies called noisy
bompton and that then also had Vice vers
doing all of my videos then I had Fool's
Gold you know what I'm saying so that
was like kind of the push that pushed me
into like
all right I'm gonna take music serious
all the way you know what I'm saying